voici aussi à sa dame de fer cette
maison atypique en son nom des matériaux
utilisés pour sa construction 100% métal
bâti en 1896 elle est une résidence
secondaire de georges de koninck et de
son épouse
la maison de fer sort de l'imagination
d'un ingénieur belge joseph d'orly c'est
un contemporain de gustave eiffel les à
9900 l'exposition universelle à l'époque
une maison de fer est installée ici à à
poissy sur les autres poissy en face de
l'hôpital et non loin des quartiers
populaires laissée à l'abandon la
structure ne résiste pas à la tempête de
1999 devenu une ruine le chantier est au
coeur d'une association en 2008 puis en
en 2015 la reconstruction est décidée
par l'équipe municipale pour en faire un
lieu culturel
elle est déplacée dans le parc
meissonnier amusé d'exposition
permanente
l'histoire de la maison de faire
l'histoire du patrimoine pisciacais mais
également des expositions éphémères
typiquement mécano vous le verrez nous a
offert l'échelle 1 12e d'une maison de
faire c'est tout simplement exceptionnel
une ouverture au public à l'occasion des
journées européennes du patrimoine
visites guidées animations théâtrales
feu d'artifice et un concert julien
clerc vous contera sa préférence